critical reading is reading what the
purpose of Critical examination of the
text and its ideas critical reading is
the process of reading texts with the
purpose to understand them fully it
involves asking questions about the
author's intention the text structure
and purpose and the meanings of
individual words and phrases
does it have a title what does the title
tell us about the piece what can we
guess from it does the title tell us
exactly what the piece is about or is it
just used to draw Us in are there any
pictures that go with the text what do
they tell us about the text are they
there just to make it look good or do
they carry information like a graph what
style of picture are they once you have
looked at the title in the pictures read
the text itself try to find out the
following things purpose audience form
context why was this written was it
written to inform to entertain to argue
to sell something or for a completely
different reason
who was this written for was it written
for children or teenagers or adults for
rich people or poor people for
Specialists or for Layman what else can
you tell about its target audience
how was this written was it written with
an essay structure a narrative structure
or some other way was it in dot points
or paragraphs was it in one big block of
text or were their lines dotted around
where was this found was it in a
newspaper a newsletter a book a poster a
flyer or somewhere else what does this
say about its purpose and target
audience
types of languages formal informal or
colloquial sophisticated technical
formal language is an academic form of
writing this means that it is language
where colloquial is avoided it also has
a touch of sophistication to it
laughs
informal or colloquial language is
language that is used in casual
conversations it can often use slang
words and usually does not include a
sophisticated vocabulary sophisticated
language means sophisticated vocabulary
these sophisticated words are sometimes
words that you would not use in your
everyday language or conversations an
example of sophisticated language is
this one Haley discovered that she had a
peculiar Fascination for aquatic Birds
technical language is language that is
used in accordance with the topic for
example if it were a poetry assignment
technical language would include
alliteration metaphor hyperbole if it
was an article on science technical
language may include chemical fossil
laboratory remember to ask yourself
these questions when reading the texts
as you go through it highlight keywords
which help you to answer these questions
and so give you a better knowledge of
the text
[Music]
foreign